[Music]
yeah congratulations thanks man although
I gotta say right when you walked out
just then I was like this guy should be
hosting your show I mean it would be a
better show but I don't think TBS could
afford me this is what he does see one
of the problems I'm running into with
the shows the audiences are so sweet and
I appreciate that but sometimes they
don't understand that I like to get I
like to get my balls my balls broken I
think it's cool that you think that you
only have one problem on the show that's
what I that's what I think people might
I think about proving anything tonight
but it's true and today yeah I have a
nice sharp image I think you you have
the persona which is fun right but on
the inside here you're like you know
jello you're like a sweet jell-o pudding
but it's on the ground for a kitten
because the kitten is like what does
that taste like and most people like
shut up kitten but it your heart is like
give it a try
I mean clearly you've given this a lot
of thought but you have an example of
one time I've been nice to you when I
did your show
there was a thank you card with a one
dollar bill in it that's true that's
true that was nice
can you teach me how to do I try and do
an impression of you sometimes okay okay
better first thing you got to dress
better you're dressed like
like you're you're the CEO of a pumpkin
patch
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah thanks for having me this is fun
[Laughter]
I'm glad you're here do yep let's keep
it to your fans let's keep it off my
general appearance Oh God
do you have weird fins yes Geico fans
yes for the cuz I'm kind of a sociopath
myself
I think weird people are attracted
towards me well I don't like I don't
meet fans after shows cuz it's gotten
pretty weird but what I will do at the
end of my set I'll but have a setlist
you know like I'm like some kind of rock
star yeah I'm like if you can trade me
something I want I'll give this to you
and people think I just mean I want
drugs but I'm not some drug addict who
needs drugs
I have drugs I just want to see what
weird things people will try to give me
yeah and I've got a mic what do you mean
you're you're like the devil yes
you're like beat me at a fiddle
competition in the lobby
you know for you just have a setlist and
you're like I don't know what you have
to offer look inside yeah yeah who once
is who's gonna step up yes I've gotten
someone gave me a shark's tooth Oh
someone gave me an alligator claw where
are you performing the Bayou a lot
most of these happened in Florida and
then I was in South Carolina and I got
the best one the best gift ever a girl
came to the stage with a self-addressed
stamped envelope from me like addressed
to her all the postage laid out and
inside was like a cylinder full of putty
that you use to make a homemade dildo
so she wanted me to open this up put it
on Oh follow the steps what does take it
off put it in envelope send it to her so
she could have sex with me forever I
need you to be honest with me
did you do it I thought about it at
first I was like of course I'm going to
do this because it was just so
flattering what concerns me is the kind
of crazy that wants a mold but also the
kind of forced sight and type a that
brings the envelope yeah so what do you
do next after this is over
[Music]